One of the most improbable experiences for me is just the career that I've had.
I grew up in a small town in Viriginia.
When I began my job, I'm not sure I even thought about what innovation was,...
...and I think now, I look at innovation as just an ongoing journey.
One of the things, I feel very passionately,...
...that I've learned and that we're trying to do more of at GE,...
...is that innovation comes in many forms.
It's a quest to be better.
It's a quest to delight, surprise, find the solutions for big, vexing problems.
I think it's much more of a calling than when I first started my career.
I'm very happy to be able to participate in that kind of scaling innovation...
...that a company like mine does.
And you're never really done.